citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to watch a movie I have wanted to see
forever that I've never seen and Greg
has seen as a child I did the math I saw
it on VHS between the ages of four to
six Craig's never seen it that does not
count you're still seeing new colors
this is RoboCop yeah we're constantly
these movie circles where people are
quoting it and I was telling you I've
been wanting to re-watch it because I
never know the references the the buy
that for a dollar I don't know why
RoboCop would say that you said it the
other day and I didn't know it was from
RoboCop until you said it yeah I was
like yeah apparently it's a Robocop I
don't know what it means I hear this
movie's actually deeper than cool
machine that kills people and a
definitely four-year-old Greg would
never have picked up on any of that it's
just a little Nuance Greg trying to
figure out the meaning of life so this
is gonna be my purpose of my rewatch
today try to recall this MB be like oh
okay this is the deeper meaning and
after dread and the nude red it felt
appropriate to dive into another thing
that got a recent remake that went the
other way though yeah where people
didn't love the new one as much but I'm
excited for this one let us know in the
comments what else you want us to watch
We're digging this action movie for Ray
we've also got a bunch of stuff coming
up and hit that subscription Bell that
like button hit all the YouTubey things
and as always thank you to the fine
folks at prepper who make this very
video possible they keep us looking good
they leave us looking efficient but you
know how you want us to look not
efficient you head on over to patreon to
watch our full reaction with those
moments that the prepper folks cut out
the full experience of our resting faces
the whole shebang over on patreon where
the super sexy rejects live without
further Ado let us RoboCop for the very
first time
[Music]
oh whoa great opening Dutch angle Flying
Dutch angle a rare touch
oh yeah let's go in the 80s now
[Music]
crime news
this is
media for three minutes and we'll give
you the world
I'm Ron Berger that's tick tock's logo
too power failed causing a brief but
harmless period of weightlessness for
the visiting president and his staff
we'll be back
interesting opening Santa come down and
talk to one of our qualified surgeons
here at the family Heart Center we
feature the complete jarvik line
extended warranties financing qualifies
for health tax credit
and remember
We Care
this is her comedy this snarky every
policeman knows when he joins the force
that there are certain inherent risks
that come with the territory ask any cop
he'll tell you he can't stand the heat
you better stay out of the kitchen
fascinating identified this man Clarence
unofficial Crime Boss of old Detroit Red
from That 70s Show at Foreman I know
that forehead anywhere
fight to save the life of Officer Frank
Fredrickson good luck Frank
this has to be like it's comedically I
know it's a satire I had no idea perfect
transferring in from Metro South nice
Precinct yeah pretty good he's got a
Killian Murphy thing about it does the
eyes are intense get your arm and suit
up
share that line get your armor and suit
what brings you to this little Paradise
it's me man I think ocp's moving a lot
of new guys up here what a bunch of
morons
they're gonna manage this department and
their white asses a lot of butts a lot
of white asses yeah try to get a Meda
back after you've been jammed well I'll
tell you what we should do we should
strike
uh-oh and I don't want to hear any more
talk about strike police officers don't
strike can you imagine a cop strike yeah
then who's gonna beat down the strikers
the billy clubs
don't worry they've got funding
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa roundhouse kick standard cop
procedure
women can't punch this Mary Sue what is
this woke [__] from the 80s man this
guy's gonna be your new partner
Murphy meet Lewis
Peter Weller is making sure to get all
his brooding stairs in there before they
were moving from him do not blink
because you will not have eyes soon
Ed 209 ran into a serious delays at cost
overruns the old man ordered a backup on
Heaven 95th
it's a lighter fire under Jones's ass
there's a great editing to this the pace
is wonderful so moved yeah and the
coverage is great sixth position Works
what about this police thing what's the
problem their Union's been pitching ever
since we took over filtered things
around I didn't realize how much of this
would be a commentary on 1980s Corporate
America is this is that what they're
doing it feels like at some point it
feels very Frank Miller yeah old Detroit
has a cancer the cancer is crime
Detroit's very different now oh yeah
yeah ask Eminem yeah I think it's time
we gave something
I love how self-congratulatory this room
is so proud of everyone and themselves
top of the food chain here thinking
about we should do something for the
little people you know building the city
we have gambled in markets traditionally
regarded as non-profit
hospitals prisons
space exploration all for profit now
every one of those
we believe in efficient police force is
only part of the solution we need a
24-hour a day police officer oh they
build the RoboCop of course they do why
would the police station the corporate
at the police stationery
plug them in plug them in laughs
corporate interest Greg oh they control
the police okay
holy [__] what is this oh actually it
does look slightly familiar to me and
they built it which is cool like that's
a thing
that's what Peter Weller's gonna oh my
God whoa It's like claymation stop
motion Holy balls this is awesome
oh sweet it's like Miniatures I think
yeah the enforcement Droid series 209 is
a self-sufficient law enforcement robot
209 is currently programmed for urban
pacification but that is only the
beginning okay
zucchini is going to help us simulate a
typical arrest and disarming procedure
this is gonna go great use your gun in a
threatening manner
pointed at Ed 209 yes sir I mean
that's a huge handgun
s to comply oh my goodness
it's roaring 10 seconds
[Applause]
look at them squibs
they just killed a guy
look at how I got it it's so violent
oh
he's just embarrassed
that's why you need a human in the suit
yeah epic I'm very disappointed I'm sure
it's only a glitch your temporary
setback could cost us 50 million dollars
in interest payments alone perhaps you
aware of the RoboCop program developed
by myself at security Concepts as it can
go see against just this sort of thing I
love how they're not concerned at all
for the person who died nope it only
that they've just their new Financial
loss
structured the police department and
placed Prime candidates according to
risk factor I'm confident that we can go
to prototype within 90 days not expect a
full presentation in 20 minutes and that
guy just lost the contract just moving
on so fast ah the cold disregard for
life too bad about Kenny huh
life's in a big city
Amen brother that's what happens you
live in a city
volunteers
[Music]
oh he's a cowboy Yeehaw my son Jimmy
watched this cop show TJ laser and his
laser guy does this every time he takes
down a bad guy and you don't want to
disappoint Role Models can be very
important to a boy true
what a weird building of chemistry yeah
right I've got a kid want to meet him
it's like the little exchanges they have
[__]
you'll find the [__] money
so he always plays angry people he's
very angry for decades he's been playing
angry people
[Music]
is that what Peter Weller's voices he
voices Batman so I think it just lives
there it just wanted a guy who sounded
like a robot
you're like a dual wielding he is a
cowboy
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh so he was a badass cop before he was
a Robocop who else you're gonna get oh
[__] clearance my legs man
I came up he's Expendable come on
Clarence just toss him on the cops car
can you fly Bobby oh he's gonna toss him
on the [__]
[Music]
don't see about what red from That 70s
Show it's not good for you
[Music]
[Applause]
what a fun score yeah it's very peppy
and Lively Central this is unit 154
we're located at Van by The Old Mill in
sector 3D Now where's that Backup backup
is still unavailable maybe we shouldn't
be a radio it yet so loud like a like a
megaphone we are now here come shoot at
us
see the millionaire criminals and the
poor criminals all have no respect for
life it's a great equalizer
there's some great camera work in this
that I was not expecting really curious
who shot it because it hasn't stopped
moving but it's not shaky at all it's
also edited like a comedy like there's
so many Cuts but they really work
I got time to pissed
[Laughter]
mind to find
zip this up
are we watching a movie or uh this is a
kind of pre-cut scene see I actually
looked at it
oh
she got distracted by his big thing yep
I like the way they build it he moved I
like how they built the world through
the media yeah it's really interesting
Dead or Alive you're coming with me oh I
know that long I've heard that line too
yeah
let us take over from here Emil
y
no oh that guy your ass is mine uh yeah
the little boy in me is getting a slight
flashback right now oh is this a moment
yeah
where's your partner other one was
upstairs
she was sweet
this guy's got some Style
you probably don't think I'm a very nice
guy
buddy I think you're slime he's scary
yeah he is he's really scary yeah cops
don't like me so I don't like cops
oh
[Music]
[__]
he's all yours oh
damn they really commit to the Practical
effects here
oh Jesus Christ
wow
how's this live
I know he's like 1980s
[Laughter]
oh man
Fun Zone
whoa crazy makeup that is rough
okay let's get out of here
yeah my brain just remembered like the
rapid fire yeah I didn't remember the
gore yeah that was intense I just
remember the rapid fire that was rough
it's actually a really well done
character setup he's got a son yeah we
know that from a line of exposition they
really make you hate these villains yeah
and they're like maniacal so they're
interesting and they're evil yeah you
want him to go and you care about him
with very little screen time they've
established like corporate greed world
and the media as a problem how is he a
still alive there's no way he got shot
in the head and dismembered with
shotguns
I mean I guess fitty got shot in the
face but not in the head like right in
there they're right in the brain that's
where he controls his impulses so when
he's at RoboCop he won't have him he's
lost like Limbs and stuff gotta pressure
60 pounds
[Music]
pressure the place was right next to the
hospital couldn't shave your nose here
Peter Weller come on Peter let's get
some blood drawn type in frosting six
units this pressure's dropping okay yeah
oh there's this kid I was at the shower
watches yeah I really have to tell you
blood pressure I've got 40 pill all
right
[Music]
whoa crazy shot will she still love you
when you're could you be a robo husband
more Robo than man okay clear
[Music]
like really effective let's go okay
why is makeup from older movies so much
better they cared and took time this is
where budgets used to go they were like
unsettling too you know oh yeah now I'm
like nauseous that's that's a lot all
right I think that's all we can do just
call it what's the time anyone notice he
has a hole in his head you guys he got
shot I think you shot the attempted that
head he gets from the head I think
oh cool is he gonna come back through
yeah POV has a Robocop
sauce oh that's so clever
[Music]
I thought we'd read on total body
prosthesis now lose the arm okay we're
gonna blank his memory anyway oh he's
trying to release forms and he joined
the forest he's legally dead we can do
pretty much what we want oh my God I
love how they just treat him like he's a
product yep he could crush every bone in
your hands all right attach it to his
shoulder
good thing you lost an arm yeah we just
took that other one off for funsies
[Laughter]
great Exposition character development
through the POV this is fun oh yeah it
is celebration of the success of him too
[Music]
[Applause]
the eeriness of treated him like a child
yeah we get the best of both worlds
fastest route is Reef with modern
technology has
not good memory and a lifetime of on the
street law enforcement programming it is
my great pleasure what a well-structured
movie
RoboCop oh
that's for you go Robo
ah great reveal that was Geniuses that's
a great handle on perspective with her
shots yeah I wonder who shot this I
think he's exceptional what's really
impressive about it to me too is that as
much of it as it feels like an 80s movie
It Feels So lived in that I don't feel a
distance with it being dated yeah this
is 40 years old almost and it doesn't
feel like that yeah because a lot of
times that datedness can feel like oh
I'm kept apart from it but yeah I feel
like more submersed in it like whether
it's dialogue or like Flavor like
they're so good yeah it's about official
ocp business
get lost hey this is [__] I take my
order from
ominous sounds of those footsteps this
is so cool
what is this [__]
cops can be replaced oh they wanted to
go on strike too because they were
afraid of artificial intelligence this
is what happens you should have gone on
Strike Boston Dynamics never watched
this movie when you're at rest you will
sit in the chair yes I understand you
can check his exact location at all
times with one of these
that sustains these Organics
you it's kind of nauseating what are
your Prime directives serve the public
trust protect the innocent uphold the
law
I will commit that to memory huh
oh classified
[Music]
ah you can see your robocops
[Laughter]
like that they didn't tell him he's just
in there
awesome
what are they gonna do replace us
I love that he's still in there by the
way he flips the gun it's really weird
because it's cool but so [__] up oh
yeah it's haunting and like evil but
like awesome go get him boy got a lot of
layers
something tells me the sequels were just
like this
robotics made it cool yeah no commentary
yeah we don't want you to think too much
I know this tune uh the strings of the
80s
[Music]
he says
shoot Somebody's gotta buy that for a
dollar I don't understand it
I love that it's a one-line cut away
like we'll never have got text with me
now move oh my God this is RoboCop
superhero origin story
two
drop the gun you are under arrest
what if you shot his mouth that's what
I've been wondering but it's so small
Maybe
oh that's 400 pounds right there he'd be
dead just from then oh yeah head off
thank you for your cooperation good
night
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh then it comes back around maybe he
does say it because he heard it yeah I
doubt it maybe it is like a superhero it
really is yeah saving the city
let the woman go you are under arrest
[Laughter]
that was amazing
that was awesome
Madam you have suffered an emotional
shock I will notify a crisis center we
will get you on a couch with
betterhelp.com only twenty dollars a
month that was so badass through the
dress thought he was doing one of those
years shoot through the like the movies
when they like shoot them in a spot
where they won't kill them yeah kill the
other guy through the address that was
awesome
I only knew shot
this movie is exceptional it is really
great the satire the comedy the action
it's all perfect it like interweaves
like in a brilliant way and the tones
all work I think if I was a kid I would
just see it as an action movie I'm kind
of glad I yeah this is great where the
hell do you think you're going keep him
talking okay Miller don't hurt the mayor
I'll give you whatever you want
says can RoboCop ever run
yeah
I want some fresh coffee and third I
want to recount he wants a recap and I
want a new car
and I want the city to pay for it all
what kind of car Miller 35 years later
he would run for president
what Plum Punk speakers what a perfect
night to for a robo cup
Crazy Craft
a thermograph
through the wall yes
[Music]
RoboCop who is he what is he where does
he come from
this storytelling device of the media is
so impressive genius
stay out of trouble
more fighting in the Mexican crisis
today when American troops participated
in a joint raid with Mexican Nationals
against Rebel rocket positions in
Acapulco the Iacocca invented the
Mustang so it's great commentary in
Corporate America smart you haven't
dismantled your MX stockpile
my border that's it Buster no more
military aid
crazy see they do like media
the commentary breaks yeah they like
push their products during like medium
warmonger uh it's crazy
there's like a real commentary on the
media that hasn't quite changed today no
it's got worse yeah vice president
Bill I'd love to but uh
a date couple models coming I I'd buy
for a dollar ah okay so it is just the
same again
just the thing people say in this city
making a real name for yourself and
security concepts with robocon you try
interesting perspective shop who is the
one [__] is the stock market in
front of them while they pee what's
what's that you know he's got this
killer rep but it's a smoke screen
space he's lost his teeth the guys are
put well now we know why would you be so
stupid to have this conversation in
public ever
I remember when I was a young executive
for this company I used to call the old
man funny names Iron Butt boner once I
even called him [__] uh-huh is that
what you guys do to me yeah
you can draw like boner over here
bastard creation of yours I had a
guaranteed military sale with Ed 209 who
cares if it worked or not the old man
thought it was pretty important
I love watching movies with two actors I
definitely know from something that I
could never place for I know and I won't
tell IMDb
you
you were the wrong guy
don't mind
oh why does it feel like there's sexual
attention there's so much you better
pray that I don't know lean monster of
yours doesn't screw up
you think they'll stick their Robo
devices
on this yeah there's got to be a third
act so yeah but I thought it would just
be with the bad guys I feel like Robocat
can take out Red Foreman pretty easy so
maybe
that is a fair boy
a human head on a robotic body yeah I
was just looking at the design of the
shoulders how clever that is
oh the PTSD
mind cannot tell the difference oh
that's cool you see a little bit of
fragmenting of like what he sees somehow
goddamn Rebels
yesterday great do you think the
peripherals would catch that [__] pretty
bad at their job
end of the lifeline
[Music]
is he going on a Revenge Mission no
RoboCop nightmares
stop wait a minute
I don't know he just left just left it's
you trying to stop Harry for chat gbt
right listening to us
this day will come
where's the AI version of Robocop that's
what I want to see who's the modern
filmmaker that's gonna make this satire
commentary because we got a lot of AI
stuff but not in this snarky way I feel
like you could remake RoboCop today with
AI yeah yeah which is right yeah
everyone wants that RoboCop remix but I
think Terminator should be like an AI
comment that'd be fun
Murphy
it's you
you really don't remember me do you
excuse me I have to go there isn't art
to acting where your mask is on oh yeah
such an art to it
what did you say
[Music]
no fall safes
yeah this all started with you you
activated it with your nightmares
walking down the hallway
now fill it up on number seven
I'm a good shot
I could hit you in the eye from here
they cast these villains really well yes
that's a piece of [__] I like to believe
they're they're hiding but believable I
bet you think you're pretty smart huh
you think you could outsmart a bullet he
is complying what do you say we find out
huh
drop it hell yeah
Dead or Alive you are coming with me
excited every time it's cathartic I hear
that right there
more context foreign
[Music]
whoa that was awesome oh that guy's dead
that that was dead yeah he's real dead
[Music]
explosion of the gas station with an
actual stunt guy that was so cool yeah
you could see him standing him amidst
the fire too yeah
wow he's he's gliding through no steps
[Laughter]
maybe it's actually got a stabilizer
image wise it could because when we see
we don't it's true area
that could be a violent weapon I enjoyed
that middle finger moment
if those known associates
it's flea
foreign
oh my God he's got his whole thing the
whole gang the whole gangs Revenge
mission
he's got really pretty lips it does they
cast well
uh oh
damn that's a mind [__] right there
yeah the movie's also a tragedy it's so
sad our lead is dead great transition to
memory yeah
can you do that Dad what happened in
there
all right
this is so sad I really have to tell you
something
oh my God she was saying something sweet
wasn't you yeah
oh there's a little smirk at the end of
that oh they cut it right before the
smoker like oh was she divorced him or
some [__] yeah man
where is Clarence
He's the bad guy from blade I think he's
in one of the blades
[Applause]
everyone's just like they hate this guy
get rid of him
how you doing oh how do they know each
other you do it
okay oh
dude
please please don't kill me all right
hello buddy boy dick Jones here
ah hired a hit you don't feel so lucky
now do you whatever he's paid you I'll
double it right now five goes on it's an
old story The Fight For Love and Glory
hubbab
Corporate America working with this bad
guy
[Music]
[Applause]
that's too bad you seemed like such a
nice guy I got the muscle you shove
enough of this Factory so far up your
stupid whop ass Frankie blow this [__]
his head off
can't can't
[Music]
come on Sal the tigers are playing
two nights I never miss a game
he is great he is so good he is really
captivating
I want to buy some cocaine
I'm low on batteries do you have cocaine
the most 80s thing ever is a dust of
cocaine and RoboCop walking through
oh
my shoes
targeting targeting
it takes a breath too I like the over
the shoulder yeah yeah
[Music]
Boogie you are under arrest you have the
right to remain silent
you
[Music]
oh yeah wait a minute I'm protected man
I've got protection you have the right
to an attorney
oh [__]
his own rules right now
JP's the senior president
anything you say may be used against you
God
is all going to record yeah I might need
it later oh yeah there we go
[Music]
it's crazy how much character they gave
RoboCop yeah
book him what's the charge say it say it
he's a cop killer Oh I thought I was
gonna say murdering Murphy yeah I
thought he was going to list all that
the lawyers will have you out in 24
hours just don't say anything else
she really screwed up he did say your
name I just got access to the camera
though right there is a tracker on him
oh but that homeboy is gonna have his
big mother effort yeah that's gonna be a
fight there's got to be someone that can
fight robocopics there's no one that
could Stakes you are under arrest
Chuck eating and abetting a known felon
sounds like I'm in a lot of trouble
[Laughter]
oh product violation oh crazy is that
the classifier yeah okay
insurance policy called direct before
senior officer both CP results in
shutdown what oh so now he's in control
Corporate America
no accountability
okay
I had to kill Bob Moore because he made
a mistake time to erase that mistake
no oh that is scary so monstrous
[Music]
oh [__]
oh damn he's actually damaged this does
that like hero and villain being the
same entity but in a really good way
oh his eyes
thank you
[Applause]
cool awesome
oh you gotta be [__] me Rockets
robo-roll
[Music]
a very good aim on this thing
the super close-ups really work for the
emotion
oh it's actually like disconcerting to
see RoboCop all front and running I'm
like okay
oh the eye is so cool oh it was not
designed for steps his big enemy stairs
my one weakness how'd they get him up
here
push him down the stairs
oh
become its friend robocon earn its Trust
it's okay they're there I don't know
they treated like it's an animal it's a
little baby
oh come on
foreign
Peter Weller
we have orders to destroy it oh [__]
see the capture the criminals the exact
same thing it
it's not an it
wow surprisingly great at raising Stakes
too yeah
jeez like all the odds are against him
right now I feel so bad for him so bad
they say you do a Superman movie like
he's you know impenetrable but we're
finding those
where's your lady cop friend
[Music]
she know to be right there is that all
just coincidence maybe she saw him
rolling
[Laughter]
modeling walks out in a suit I I am so
surprised by how truly fantastic not
gonna lie people were like this movie's
deeper than people giving credit and I
was still like I was like yeah maybe
sure whatever Robo guy yeah no this is
like a four and a half Stars
that thing is still alive
I don't know what you're talking about
the police officer arrested you the one
you spilled your guts to see how they
did
yeah
allergy nasal is pretty uh Clarinex yeah
he recorded every word you said his
memory is admissible as evidence you
involved me you're gonna have to
kill me admissible good word we're gonna
need some major Firepower got access to
military weaponry we practically are the
military oh this movie's got some things
to say
same privatized military and privatized
police are a problem Greg
corporate interest May hinge on those
beliefs in a system that works yep cool
Robo guy but this Robo guy yeah
did you bring the gun
the precinct was deserted half the
forest didn't show up for work today my
God he just sounding like a dude now
yeah they're humanizing them
your gun
you asked for this I brought you some
food
oh thank you I'm not hungry oh this is a
sweet boy I love you RoboCop you got my
heart oh he's unscrewing his head oh
we're gonna see a maskless what's
underneath
where's the sun in my they moved but oh
my God it that's what they meant by the
freaking Guardians Guy what's his name
yeah I never got that reference
[Music]
you're very much Society it is
a gray bar Hotel not bad they let me
keep the shirts
they let me out of jail for free damn
they've all got let out what do you got
through Clarence
whoa whoa watch this demonstration
[Applause]
is this the same warehouse where Murphy
was born
I was gonna say I love the synchronicity
of her being with him again for the end
against them but in the same place yeah
is it the same spot
oh it's kind of creepy with his mask
yeah
human face move that way I still care
about you I'm just uncomfortable
[Applause]
yeah dude what are you doing don't tell
them where you are
those fierceness in his eyes
[Music]
if they aim on that kind of Cannon could
not be easy
the last thing I forget to dissociate
with this movie is that it's
surprisingly moving yeah it's like
actually like it gets you in the field
surprisingly okay
anyway
a little little skip there right into
the toxic waste
no he'll be back as a super villain in
the sequel he's the joker now
ace chemicals
oh my God what's happening
I thought he was just gonna be dead
oh it's melting oh man the 80s were
different what is happening he's a Toxic
Avenger well that was so gross they
melted him
that was so disturbing wow I thought it
was just gonna roll out yeah
oh man I thought everybody treats him
like he's the worst one of them all oh
100.
[Music]
oh the other side of his face is even
worse
what is happening this guy
he came up in his Golem
oh yeah you liquefied him
I don't know why this movie hates
himself much
this keeps picking on him they just
liquefied him
oh [__] that's what I was worried about
God damn it oh wow characters really get
shot this one got blown up
oh you walk on water my resurrected man
that's right
[Music]
oh
yeah a little too late I mean yeah but
at least he's dead
oh [__] oh
Terminator to take some oh my god oh can
you get him oh oh right of the jugular
you got way too
I'm a mess they'll fix you
everything
it makes everything
dick Jones is wanted for murder these
are serious charges what is your
evidence
yeah plug it in I had to kill Bob Morton
because he made a mistake now it's time
to erase that mistake
I want a chopper now oh but protect they
could it could override with a directive
hey fire him can it dick
[Music]
[Applause]
damn good call right because immediately
directives I don't know what you meant
by that yeah
his arms were alone
very poorly saved it for the end
nice shooting son what's your name
Murphy
again
oh hell yeah
damn talk about a movie that lives up
that was so good that age is incredibly
that is one shot I didn't like it
it's in the last 30 seconds
wow that was so good it wow I'm actually
like really Blown Away by it I I really
went in going
that I was kind of going in thinking
that maybe
maybe I'd be a little bored until they
finally became
I don't care about anybody
like free conceived Notions for some
reason like ah baby it's gonna be
whatever yeah and then maybe it's like
over hyped and and but no that was that
was a genuinely like phenomenal
experience genius attire genius comedy
in and out of universe like the way it
addressed us and the action in the DP
was like insanely good I love the
editing I love the way it was filmed I
loved like the writing was fantastic
that was so good
I
I'm kind of Blown Away by it because it
does so much it's got the social
commentary of the political commentary
commentary that's relevant to even today
that I wasn't expecting yeah uh uh the
the the fear of replacing uh that I mean
obviously all the stuff about like
Corporate America and whatnot and and
Military and workers rights but but then
it also like just had menacing villains
and a really solid character in Robocop
and for some reason they'll tip it did
the t09 sorry he's like a legend Phil
tip it's like one of the best visual
effects artists
my my knowledge on that is not
the most wide but yeah that was probably
my my big my biggest surprise was how
much I cared about RoboCop because
kind of like you could say Superman or
kind of even like when we watch dread
like I love dread easily one that's
probably one of my favorite reaction
videos we've ever done ever on this
channel
um but one of my things about it was I I
never really fear for dreads right at no
point did I think and I love the stakes
escalating here yeah to the point where
I was like how are they gonna make the
villains worth fighting how are they
going to make me worry about RoboCop but
then by the end I was like are they just
gonna rebuild him in part two like I
thought he might actually die yeah and
that's impressive for a movie to make me
worry about or lead to that level yeah I
was I I really felt for Murphy the
character the the way how you know
you'll have like the superhero identity
but then the person underneath who they
really are sure with their first name
right and I I didn't expect to connect
so much to Murphy because in all honest
it's like I like I like Peter Weller it
was like reasonably Charming enough sure
before he became RoboCop so the last
thing I expected was so like it more
whispered to evolve as a character with
me foreign
all right I thought we got our movie
um and I thought like the main voice
character of the movie would be like
what the movie's talking about it would
be the real it would be the real
character I didn't expect so much to
care about RoboCop himself I thought
he'd just be like an aesthetically
pleasing guy and it was really neat but
I I felt for him and and I thought it
was tragic and and and uh yeah when he
was getting like shot when like the bad
guys are coming down and the cops coming
down I'm like man it's so messed up he's
already had such a terrible life but
like yeah they're terrible for this guy
Catherine Hardwick did the TJ laser
stuff I don't know any of these people
Catherine Hardwick's uh director of hurt
locker and like oh James Cameron yeah
that's what I know whereas that's your
only identity to me that's like a huge
director she started on Point Break
that's huge
did she do the first Twilight
anyway uh was it her I don't think
that's correct I don't know I know the
first I know the director of the first
file I did Lords of Dogtown but I can't
place if that's the same director anyway
she was like uh the laser crew the one
who did 13. yeah I'm gonna look it up
I'm gonna do the Cardinals I gotta know
uh but yeah I was really impressed with
like everything they were able to do
with Nuance but also the commentary on
so many different things never clouded
the other like it had so many different
tones but they never crossed over and
made it like oh that's invalidated
that's invalidated yeah and some of the
visuals were like oh when he gets the
mirroring of the the criminal shooting
him to death to the cop shooting him to
death being a mirroring of the
commentary on the whole movie and using
some of the visual Aesthetics and
everything was genius oh great point
they literally cut to a side shot of
more cops shooting him with the same uh
angle as they did with the five bad guy
and I thought that was genius there's
there's a lot of re-watch ability sure
that I that I wasn't expecting to pick
up on either I oh yeah there's yeah
definitely little I think the only thing
I really remember was like a flash of
him getting shot up
like when you were a kid yeah yeah yeah
because that's pretty funny as a child
what have I seen
the arm getting blown the hand getting
blown off I didn't remember that yeah it
was so rough that was crazy but I don't
know I saw a lot of violence when I was
younger yeah all players together it all
blurs together after a while uh
the movie was also very huh I don't
think we've ever even learned his first
name that's and he was so compelling who
Murphy
that was his first name it wasn't wasn't
Murphy I was assumed it was officer
Murphy because Murphy was on his badge
wouldn't that be your last name
like don't you go by like you'd be Alba
I assumed that it wasn't like Murphy
Brown no because it said it said Murphy
on his uh on his name uh on his jacket
yeah so I think we never even learned
his first name oh interesting that's
just an interesting way to like that's
compelling me we don't even know a full
uh I mean I thought the I thought the
movie also too was
what I loved about this kind of
dystopian future and as we said a lot
during the reaction so I'm trying not to
just repeat everything we said but what
I love about this kind of dystopian
future is that it felt very tangible as
well you know I I think
from what I recall about the reboot of
Robocop and and recall and like the
total recall
for the trailers I've seen of that is
that it's just so hyper CGI and so
futuristic you know it's like everything
tries to become like Blade Runner all
the sudden or something like that yeah
Fifth Element I would say you know and
it keeps his hands and so here this is
uh this this felt like very this felt
plausible like this felt believable in
in a lot of ways and I think the the way
they did the shots too like there's a
lot of these great tracking shots here
with like superb editing as well and
it's it's like consistently menacing but
it's got that like real Twisted kind of
sense of humor yeah you know yeah I was
really impressed with some of the shots
the fact that POV worked in this so well
POV rarely works for me I'm usually like
that's a gimmicky shot but they use POV
in such an event of way when not only is
he dying and then the reboot that
narratively is great but then they were
able to reincorporate that rebooted
image to give us a POV of him to give us
characterization he's only showing this
much of his face because you're living
with his view yeah which is genius the
propaganda commentary oh my God the
commercials were genius how they made
the because it's all focuses on Detroit
but the media gives you a sense of the
world I also can't believe it's like
it's set in Detroit which is the
American cart City and there were so
many commentaries on like original car
consumerism like Lee Iacocca is the guy
that invented the Mustang which was huge
for the city of Detroit Lee Iacocca
school is a commentarian like
consumerism to a level they've got the
car that's got 8.3 miles per gallon in a
city that's known for building gas
guzzling cars when the gas guzzling cars
went away Detroit crumbled like all of
that layers oh [__] I didn't know all
that yeah so like that's a genius
commentary on just the American
consumerism with corporate America with
destroying the planet consumerism that's
a big part of the film that is a huge
part of the film but yeah the car stuff
was genius because if you don't know
you're not distracted but if you do know
you're like Lee Iacocca Drop Like that's
crazy yeah
this movie is deeper than he is crazy
good it's actually like really deep but
it's but it also is a very just
entertaining film yeah at no point was I
not like enjoying the giddiness of a
good action movie even while I was going
like that's so smart like some movies
are heavy-handed enough that it leaves
the action behind because you're
thinking and that's fine for that tone
but at no point did I leave the action
movie while also thinking because you
have to be like because I could also see
how this thing spawned into a action
franchise with a TV there's like a live
action TV series that I've never seen
and then there's the animated TV series
which cannot be nuanced it is in video
games you know like I could totally see
how RoboCop became that yeah based off
of just what a Robocop is because it's
so cool because you see it's so cool and
all
um but the but this first movie I kind
of don't even want to watch this I'm
really scared I I don't want to because
I feel like it would just like
upset me it'll like Sully this it's the
opposite of dread where like the new
one's amazing and it makes the first one
better I'm afraid this will be like
diminishing returns I think that's
exactly how it would go I'd be surprised
if it I don't know how you could
possibly this is like a per it's almost
perfect I give this four and a half
Stars which I rarely do like this is a
very high this might be my favorite
thing we've watched yeah I think my only
thing is like I like the the lady
I like she's the reason I like her uh
but they're and I I care more about them
when they were connected post to him
taking off the map yeah that those parts
I did care about more but there was
occasionally these things with the with
this sweeter more like tender dramatic
scenes that's a little weird because
they played odd instead of like natural
like yeah it didn't feel natural
um and so other than like those little
little things there's yeah there's not
too much very tiny there's very
intermittent things that I would forget
about that I'm like oh yeah yeah
whatever that's not that guy has really
long arms
they like gave him prosthetic arms to
make the the depth of field look like he
was falling faster but instead he just
had really long arcs oh the makeup was
phenomenal God crazy makeup like what
they were able to do with that like now
High evolutionary look but like what
they were able to do with making it look
like he was plastered to metal and like
how he was in the suit is so genius like
I really felt like that was a Robocop
did they pull that off in some ways it
looks more impressive than high
evolutionary yeah 87 in the face right
yeah I mean still impressive but God
damn
this movie was really cool yeah it was
like it was like constantly unsettling
but but always captivating yeah
um
yeah I loved it I really loved it I
didn't expect to walk away I thought
this was I thought it was uh I thought
it might have been a little overhyped
the 80s is also like the height of like
raw raw spend I didn't expect things to
be like it's dangerous to live this way
like this was a movie that we made now
that like certain news channels would
complain about like this is a movie that
could exist today with the same
commentary that would be like oh won't
go broke and instead it was in the
height of that era I watched Terminator
one quite a lot growing up yeah
um mainly because Terminator 2 is like
arguably my favorite movie of all time
I like this more uh but I'm not I don't
I don't love Terminator one as much as I
maybe I should
I wish I felt a lot of it is just to
like get determinated
I don't I'm not as in love with it I I
like this morning Terminator one this is
like one of my favorite action figures
by quite a bit I actually I I like this
more than terminal one like the the
action is not maybe the best sure like
but that's that was the thing is that's
not my main takeaway with this film
because the action is relatively simple
walks around
but it's all the emotional surrounding
context around the action that makes it
so interesting and and and and
worthwhile and the cinematography makes
up for the action for me exactly yeah
like maybe no point maybe the
choreography is the greatest yeah
because you've got a guy that only has
so many hinges like what can you do like
the fact that he even did some cool over
the shoulders I was like that's
impressive whereas I would be like even
Terminator Terminator two came out a few
uh several years after this but
Terminator 2's action sequences I'm
still like oh those are phenomenal yeah
some of the best of all time yeah
whereas here I wouldn't say like the
action figures are here are phenomenal
but the the context around them are so
good but every but every scene felt so
important I think James Cameron's wife
uh ex-wife is Catherine Bigelow and
Catherine Hardwick is the one that
directed Twilight and Lords of Dogtown
I mixed it because I'm like there's no
way the person that directed Twilight
also directed hurt longer like doesn't
feel right I think Catherine Bigelow
Catherine Hardwick are dude for people
yeah I think James Cameron's wife is
Catherine Bigelow uh I was just so
bothered by that I'm like there's no way
she directed all of those things uh but
yeah James Cameron's obviously got an
action aesthetic that influenced so much
but this influenced way more than I
realized we said you know there were
some lines of dialogue but also I do
think you're right there's some
Terminator moments here in this first oh
yeah but this stabbing yeah I was like
that's like straight up what happens in
Terminator 2. some of those frames are
the same yeah this was so impressive
this might be my favorite thing we've
reacted to ever and I loved dread like
this and Dread are my top two yeah I
just love I love the mood uh throughout
because the move was was changing but ah
that was I'm kind of I'm kind of I'm
taking it back a little bit
yeah that was that that is a wildly
impressive film sometimes when you do
these reactions it's hard because like
you know you're on camera and you're
aware that like you're watching
something and sharing it and that's
harder to ruminate on like sometimes we
film so I'm like okay my day's on like
and I leave but this is something I'm
like oh I just watched a thing that I
know I'm gonna think about I want to
watch it again I like found myself going
if I set it during it like if this plays
in the theaters I want to go see it 100
this is playing it like The Arrow or
some like you know old movie theater I'd
love that it's so well crafted and the
music's [__] amazing too and it's
it's cathartic like yeah this was this
was a surprising I I feel like I
shouldn't be surprised yeah everyone
hyped it and it's even better yeah yeah
I think that's a I think it was just so
hyped that most of the time people do
that [__] it's it's it can't be
delivered and I'm like it's a [__]
80s movie about a machine about a
robocopy yeah also like an 80s movie
it's really hard to live up to people's
expectations of their age when they
watched it like we weren't 17 watching
this yeah we were I mean I wasn't even
alive yet but we weren't yet like in
that era so I was really worried about
people that love it just having
Nostalgia because their parents might
have showed them that's what I thought
it was a Nostalgia you know what I mean
there was no Nostalgia tied to this
except for I've seen the figures of Robo
but I was like but I bet it's a little
boring that's what I thought I was never
born not once not once I was bored I
thought it was really interesting the
entire time and and it does have more in
its my mind and you can see like I can
see I was the same guy made Starship
Troopers I can't wait to read essays on
this like I'm excited to like read about
it I don't feel that often anymore where
I'm like I can't wait to learn the
things I missed
before we go you want to just see what
like the other robocops are rated yeah
I was thinking about like how did they
do really because this was amazing
because what if like RoboCop 2's all
right what if like three is a sneaky hit
like we just don't know about it because
two sucked like there's like one more
good one I heard one of them if I'm not
mistaken a fun fact just popped into my
head I heard one of them is PG-13 whoa
which is like a Telltale that's a crime
we need to how many robocops are there
is that the show you were talking about
why is there like 20 robocops I don't
know what these other robocops are
Resurrection I don't know the names
Paige Fletcher does not yeah I have no
idea oh 49 for the new one God damn oh
damn oh my God nine percent on three
nine oh Robert a Peter Weller didn't
even return for well after you get a 28
dude ripped horns hit one
28. only 40 people watched it from
Rotten Tomatoes oh damn even the
audience score is terrible dude it's got
a 40 reviews for real critics 50 000
audience ratings 36 dude that is rough
oh I I don't know if I'm 101 I don't
think I don't I don't think we need it
uh oh God 50 000.
I mean regardless
the asinine Circle should be placed
under arrest maybe we skip two and go
right to three yeah because I was like a
really fun time okay Frank Miller
co-wrote oh dude do you want to just
watch three like because I don't want to
be sullied but if it's this bad maybe if
we skip you know what I mean did Frank
Frank Miller co-wrote two and three and
they're terrible oh because it's so it's
the first one so Frank Miller
he didn't he didn't co-write this one
well this feels like what influenced a
lot of his Comics so it's interesting
that wow dude nine we've never done a
nine percent movie
damn the Remake has better reviews but
then either of the sequels the Remake
has a better audience score and reviews
uh God damn that is crazy but I mean
still nothing still not great what about
it Samuel Jackson Ooh Jackie Earl Haley
oh I love Abby Cornish maybe we should
just skip to the remake
I mean three in the dream it could be
funny but it's just a remake it looks
like it's such a reason look at how bad
that image is that image is just my suit
is so cheesy yeah look at how much again
red visors he's just wearing a Power
Ranger suit he's just literally like I
think rope but like this came out like
what 10 years ago yeah I I think it was
one of the first trailer reactions I
ever heard and I remember being so hyped
for it no at 10 years ago Greg plays to
the kind of audience member that oh
that's so funny like oh you got the
sweet slick version of Robocop guys it's
so edgy he's corporate branded he's got
the C on his chest and it's like this
the fact that it exists is kind of the
what RoboCop stands against the fact
that there's three of them and shows
Corporate America made a show an
animated show and a sequel yeah that's I
mean I'm down man
that was uh this first one's Immaculate
though I cannot believe how good that
was I don't know if I could sit through
those other two that just sounds awful
that does sound rough all right I don't
know what these other robocars
the animated films are like what are
they well it's like I don't know live
action what is this action sci-fi the
rated R hour and a half MGM television
what
Robocop and cable find refuge in the
temple of a techno-religious order
they're just making stuff up
all right well that exists what did they
do to report
you ruined my favorite movie I love this
so much stop making them she ruined up
Jesus do you think we should do the 10
year ago
I'm giving you a fun comparison yeah you
think we should we do two and three or
just which I think just skip two yes
okay go right to this I I can't do that
too much yeah I love the okay yeah and
that way we don't have an association
because it's so much newer it won't feel
I mean it won't feel connected yeah all
right you let us know yeah dear audience
let us know if we should watch 2014's
RoboCop with the understanding it will
not be as good uh we know what we're
getting into should we watch 2014 Joel
kenneman Robocop let us know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this
journey as much as we did please do hit
that like hit that notification Bell and
hit that comment on what you want us to
watch next I'm loving these action
movies it has been an absolute blast so
please let us know what you want us to
dive into and we'll be back with some
more goodness soon thank you for being
here thank you for watching much love
reject Nation we'll see you soon
foreign